well we just have so much news after the
long holiday weekend and we have to
start with arguably the biggest news in
the world Tulsi gabbard has left the
Democratic Party
and she's done it with a pretty
conspiracy and lie Laden video now this
is actually not very big news I'm sort
of kind of kidding around its
tongue-in-cheek uh Tulsi gabbard is an
individual who used to be a
congresswoman representing the state of
Hawaii and she ran for president and got
you know like one kind of like a one one
two percent support
um and then she although it was obvious
to some of us that she was clearly a
sort of populist rhetoric reactionary
contrarian of no real substance adding
no real value to the conversation
um not everybody understood that even
some of my fellow leftists kind of fell
for it and she's been more and more
outwardly moving to the right speaking
at CPAC the extreme right wing
convention
um being selected to fill in his host
for Fox News propaganda Tucker Carlson
and listen this is the final step in her
public transformation it's really not
that much of a transformation so here is
the video 80 seconds in which tool C
announces her principled and defiant
abandonment of the Republican Party
listen closely because there's a lot of
uh a lot of nonsense in here I can no
longer remain in today's Democratic
party that's under the complete control
of an elitist cabal of War mongers now
elitist cabal
that is very carefully chosen language
to appeal to the reactionary
conservative Maga big lie JFK Jr is
currently the vice president type of
people elitist cabal is Q Anon language
do not think that the choice of that
language is an accident now I'm not
saying tool C is necessarily A Q Anon
person I'm not saying that but that's
language that is
finely tuned and tested to press the
buttons in the abrains of very
particular people it's not an accident
okay and by the way warmongers remember
Hillary was going to get us into five
Wars Biden was going to get us into five
Wars none of it has happened okay none
of it has happened but they love to say
these are just these are Maga right-wing
conspiracy talking points who were
driven by cowardly wokeness who div
remember the wokeness what they think of
as wokeness is the tiniest sliver of the
left it's not me it's not really my
audience it's not the Democratic party
it's a yeah it's same old stuff guide us
by racializing every issue okay the
criticism that the left racializes
everything is a way to disqualify
a priori any discussion of racism or
racial inequality that that you you go
they racialize everything hard right
move she's gone fully in and stoking
anti-white racism and that's the other
side
the left is anti-white and racist
against whites
the left is mostly white guys that's
that's the reality
who actively work to undermine our
god-given freedoms that are enshrined in
our constitution who are hostile to
people of faith and spirituality and
again it's not hostility to people of
Faith or spirituality it's hostility to
imposing that Faith or spirituality on
civil government it's about openly as
Marjorie Taylor Greene and Beau bear and
all of them have said saying we are
Christian nationalists and that should
be enshrined in civil law that's wrong
that's not constitutional
who demonized the police but protect
criminals at the expense of law-abiding
Americans and remember the number of
people saying defund the police
it's almost zero and the movement has no
power reform absolutely the 10 to 12
point plan I outlined of course but this
is again their new talking point but
remember when they didn't like what
happened on January 6 they went after
the Capitol Police when they didn't like
what happened with Donald Trump at
Mar-A-Lago they go after the FBI they're
not the pro police pro-law enforcement
people they even claim to be
who believe in open borders who
weaponize the National Security State to
go after their political opponents
that's a trump line
this is a full Maga person now
and above all who are dragging us ever
closer to nuclear war
isn't the guy threatening the nuclear
war Putin the one who's actually doing
that now I believe in a government
that's of the People by the people and
for the people oh unfortunately today's
Democratic party does not instead it
stands for a government that is of by
and for the powerful Elite
now I'm calling on my fellow Common
Sense independent-minded Democrats to
join me in leaving the Democratic Party
All right so then she says leave the
party with me so she uses all the
buzzwords that will make the right love
her even more she really hasn't been a
Democrat for as long as I can remember
she's essentially a reactionary who puts
her finger to the wind and says you know
I didn't get any real attention from the
left other than the small cult of
personality I managed to kind of
coalesce around me because I don't
really bring anything to the table so
let's go to the place where you don't
need to bring anything substantive to
the table I can just use buzzwords and
talking points and talk about an elitist
cabal and get attention that's the
conspiracy right that's the Maga right
Hillary was right again guys she is once
again doing the bidding
of the Russians again not a Russian
asset not a Russian agent this is the
type of democracy destabilizing language
that the Russians and the Chinese and
everybody loves now again you can say
well but listen
good for them then doesn't mean fine I'm
just saying the idea that she is
fundamentally acting in the best
interest of the United States as she
claims is obviously not true she's
becoming a great tool of these
authoritarian uh uh right-wing regimes
that love to frame the United States as
being unstable democratically and quite
frankly we are to some degree but it's
thanks to people like this not that
they're pointing out they're causing
that oh Trump really won all this
different stuff so here come the book
deals here come the speaking engagements
if you follow the the sort of money
Trail it leads to the same type of
people they monetize being anti-woke
they monetize
um all the stuff that Tulsi is talking
about here the saddest thing about the
entire Tulsi episode and it is very sad
is the number of fellow leftists who
were Bamboozled by Tulsi I'm glad I
never fell for it go back to my clip in
January of 2019 watch the video I do
about her watch it and you will see how
obvious it was to me at the time what
she was up to sadly many of my
colleagues fell for it but
you can redeem yourself now it's
becoming very clear even to many of them
and I've gotten so many emails from
people in the audience saying David I
totally fell for it you were right I
fell for it I think this is the final
Loop we can close the envelope and mail
it in a bad news for Herschel Walker
we're still waiting on new Herschel
Walker polling I think although I'll
take a look in a moment as to whether we
have new polling uh Herschel Walker it
turns out urged his girlfriend to have a
second abortion she says to the New York
Times this is reported by CNBC so
remember the story here
was that early last week this Scandal
broke wherein Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker who claims to
be against abortion in all cases uh
abortion is murder no exceptions for
incest rape life of the mother none of
it none of it turns out that he was
accused credibly with receipts of urging
and then paying for an ex-girlfriend of
his to get an abortion because it would
have been inconvenient remember
abortions murder
rape incest no inconvenience was a
legitimate reason for him to urge and
then pay for a woman to get an abortion
the new report is he actually urged her
to get a second abortion and she didn't
uh CNBC rights a woman who accused
Herschel Walker of paying for her
abortion in 2009 revealed he urged her
to end a second pregnancy
per the New York Times the woman said
their relationship ended after she
refused to have the second procedure
according to the report the trump-backed
Georgia Republican running to unseat
Rafael Warnock has denied paying for an
abortion that denial is not particularly
credible at this point in time Walker
has denied knowing who the woman is
despite reporting from both the times
and the daily beasts that she's the
mother of a son she had with Walker so I
believe there's four
I I don't have it in front of me but I
believe that there's four women at least
with whom he's had children
you would think that he would say well
if it's one of those four women I must
know who it is it's all crazy and the
question now is will this end the
candidacy we still don't have any new
polling I I hope by tomorrow or later
today there will be new polling taken
after the Scandal started
he should be done
whether he will be is unclear because
many of these Georgia Republicans are
rationalizing the whole thing and saying
well he would still ban abortion he fine
he went and paid for one but he would
still vote to ban it
um let's see what the new polling shows
Raphael Warnock should be winning by 40.
they tentatively had a debate scheduled
for this Friday uh Walker has reportedly
still not confirmed that he will be
there and so we will follow that closely
and if indeed they do have that debate
you can be sure that I will be streaming
that live Donald Trump's lawyers are now
turning on each other it is getting very
ugly and predictably so law and crime
has a very good piece Trump's lawyers
turning against each other
legal experts react to the report that
Christina Bob said she was told to sign
the alleged false statement about
Mar-A-Lago documents this is really
interesting what's going on I mean of
course it's it's a train wreck it's a
car crash in every way but it's also
interesting legal Twitter was a buzz
over reports that one of former
president Trump's attorneys recently
spoke with Federal prosecutors about
various details regarding allegedly
classified documents discovered at
Mar-A-Lago according to NBC News uh
citing three sources familiar with the
matter attorney Christina Bob a one-time
talking head on one America news named
two other Trump attorneys involved with
the case during a recent talk with the
U.S department of justice as long crime
previously reported
Bob signed a letter in June of this year
um
saying that Trump had returned all
documents subject to a May grand jury
subpoena we know that wasn't true that
letter claimed Trump no longer had any
documents identified as classified at
his Florida estate the statement Bob
signed however was allegedly authored by
Trump attorney Evan Corcoran according
to the New York Times the report is that
she now is saying I was told to sign it
I didn't believe that it was true I'm
another one of these victims here and
very very quickly it is not only Trump
attorneys getting attorneys but it is
Trump attorneys pointing the finger at
other attorneys now there's a legitimate
legal question how solid is your defense
if you say I knew it was false but they
told me to sign it
different legal opinions have come down
on this some say uh this is actually not
a crime that Christina Bob committed I'm
relaying what someone else told me uh as
long as she is telling the truth about
that and there is an evidence that this
was her idea her thought to sign and put
together this document that someone told
her to it to do it you can make the case
that she has not committed any crime
that's one legal opinion the other legal
opinion is she is confessing that she
knew that what she was being told is
false you know it there's this legal
idea of
um the lawyers are following what their
clients tell them they believe and it is
not really up to the lawyer to determine
whether they are being told something
that's true or false but if she is
admitting she knew that it was false and
still signed off on it I've also read
legal opinions that say no she could
also be in legal Jeopardy what we know
is Christina Bob was hired by Trump for
her ability to be a talking head on
television and that is often how Donald
Trump hires his lawyers we will have to
see where this all falls but it is an
extremely uh risky from a career
standpoint decision to agree to be
Donald Trump's attorney so Trump's
attorney is now pointing fingers at each
other and I predict in the next month
it's going to get very very interesting
where this Falls let me know what you
expect find me on Twitter at dpacman and
we will be back right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right so Donald Trump held two
rallies over the weekend we are really
getting into just the very very end here
of the 2022 midterm campaign period we
have debates this week next week the
week after I'll be live streaming a
bunch of them Donald Trump's rally
schedule has gotten very busy and each
of these rallies Wilder and crazier than
the previous let's go in reverse
chronological order Donald Trump
speaking Sunday night or afternoon as it
were in Arizona in support of Kerry Lake
and Blake Masters and other really
dangerous extreme candidates Donald
Trump was completely completely
completely incoherent talking about the
planting of documents jumping back and
forth between they were my documents and
I had the right to have them at
Mar-A-Lago
to they planted the documents listen to
this making no sense soaking wet Trump
dripping wet as he tells these lies
National Archives put a trigger warning
on the Constitution of the United States
did you know that and the Bill of Rights
and other great documents that we have
in our country founding documents
trigger considering them to be dangerous
they consider the Constitution
to be dangerous these are radical left
lunatics and they lose documents they
plant documents oh let's see is there a
book on nuclear destruction or the
building of a nuclear weapon cheaply
let's put that box let's put that book
in with Trump
no they plant documents I mean they have
a terrible reputation so Trump now
saying despite at the very same rally
saying listen these were my documents
they took them they got to give them
back they're my documents now he's
saying well they planted stuff and it
included a book on how to make a nuke
wow that's a new allegation I hadn't
heard that before Trump then says listen
everything they found was mine they
should give it all back wait but I
thought you said they planted the stuff
was it yours or was it not yours
they don't get enough credit by contrast
I had a small number of boxes in storage
at Mar-A-Lago guarded by secret service
and my people and everybody I mean it's
safe when you look at
these other people what they did and the
FBI raided my home and violated my
fourth amendment rights and many other
rights and under the Sox decision this
is a very important decision that was
made to court the Sox decision because
again it had to do with Bill Clinton and
his socks
there is no crime you know there is no
crime it's not a crime
and
they should give me immediately back
everything that they've taken from me
because it's mine right oh wait but I
thought you said they planted it so now
he says it's his stuff give it back fine
but for a while like five minutes
earlier the story was the stuff was
planted another completely unbelievable
moment Arizona gubernatorial Republican
candidate Kerry Lake talks about Hunter
Biden's crack pipe really elevating the
discourse at these rallies now I gotta
tell you yeah I have some of these know
nothing Consultants who tell me you know
you really need to back away from
president Trump right now
and I say to them
right now
wouldn't it be horrible wouldn't it be
horrible what would it say about my
character if I stepped away from my
friends if I step away from my friends
that means I would step away from you
and I will never step away from the
people of Arizona
and so for those know-nothing
consultants and the media I want to show
you what it looks like when I step away
from president Trump show us
and gives Trump a big hug there so
really just out of control with the
hunter Biden stuff and then uh she and
by the way she could win she's leading
by like a point or two right now she
that woman could be the next governor of
Arizona as scary and horrifying as that
is and then uh Donald Trump now also the
anti-trans and parents rights portion of
these speeches it's a staple at every
rally now
one of the first things we must do is
stand up for parents rights can you
believe I'm even saying that we're going
to fight for parents rights who would
ever think you have to say that
we're going to fight for parents rights
10 years ago if you said that they say
you're crazy what of course you're going
to fight for parents rights today you
have to make a case for it we will get
critical race Theory out of our schools
out of our military which we had it out
and out of every part of our federal
state and local governments and at long
last every parent in America must be
empowered to opt out of the forced
indoctrination in the classroom and send
their child to the public private
Charter religious or home school of
their choice then he goes on to say no
teacher should be allowed to teach
transgender whatever that means without
parental permission so that is now a
staple of the rallies that's the Arizona
rally Trump dripping wet confused
extreme but that was nothing compared to
the previous day's rally in Nevada which
is where we're going to go next Donald
Trump had a rally on Saturday in Nevada
and at this rally his brain genuinely
appeared to malfunction and break he
talked about a Chinese restaurant
bowling alley at which documents were
reportedly stored as if it somehow means
that what he did with his documents at
Mar-A-Lago is okay okay listen to this
story that Trump told Joy
[Music]
Georgetown weather
in a bowling alley slash Chinese
restaurant
now what's the truth of the story the
truth is that uh when the National
Archives
um is participating in the process of
the creation of a Presidential Library
they will often
um rent or lease some space wherever uh
the library is being built or close to
where they are working and it is true
that the National Archives Nara they
leased uh what was essentially a
warehouse to temporarily store documents
for George H.W bush in College Station
Texas it was a building that at one
point was a bowling alley and part of
the building was a Chinese restaurant
Trump wants to frame it as George H.W
bush took a whole bunch of documents
just like Trump did and put them at what
was at the time a functioning bowling
alley or Chinese restaurant that's not
what happened Nara properly in control
of documents lease the space that used
to be that it has no connection
whatsoever to what Donald Trump did and
every one of these story has like a
kernel of Truth
wrapped in 99 lies Trump going on during
this speech about when are they going to
prosecute Bill Clinton and Hillary
Clinton and all of them
I believe that what do you think yes yes
Mike
when will they investigate and prosecute
Bill Clinton Hillary Clinton George Bush
and look into what took place with
George Bush's father a very nice man and
the warehouse of documents and what
about Barack Hussein Obama Obama
potential prosecution I don't think so I
don't think they are
a Chinese restaurant at a bowling alley
yeah so Trump just focusing on they
should all be prosecuted of course they
didn't do any of the things that Donald
Trump did Trump also fixating on Bill
Clinton and a sock drawer but he
pronounces it a sock draw it's a it's
it's very interesting
they're still looking for those things
to a former car dealership in Arkansas
we love Arkansas I can tell you we won
Arkansas about times also and kept
classified recordings in his sock draw
sock draw in fact he supposedly put the
information from the White House into
his socks
these rallies are so insane at another
Point Trump very dangerously bragged
about how big the crowd was on January 6
2021 as if that's something to cheer
about given the hell and destruction
that that crowd Unleashed but the crowd
in Nevada seems to like it and these
corrupt people will never take a camera
and turn it around and show them how
many people are here they never do it
they're corrupt
yeah
they never do it you know I never knew
the cameras because this took place
right from they never want to show how
massive our crowd was you know the
biggest crowd I've ever seen
January
six
and you never
and the crowd loves it by the way the at
these rallies the crowd constantly is
booing and and sort of jeering the media
at the back of the rally the only media
at the back of these rallies are right
wing outlets right side broadcasting and
Newsmax and Newsmax didn't even cover
Trump's Arizona rally so I don't know
what they're complaining about uh then
Trump does the Q Anon music and during
the Q Anon music he complains about
commercial airports which by the way
Trump doesn't ever go to because he
flies private and it's weird but it's
also kind of funny in a way check this
out a nation was once revered airports
are dirty and a crowded mess you sit and
wait for hours and then are notified
that the plane won't leave and they have
no idea when they will where ticket
prices have tripled they don't have the
pilots to fly the planes and they don't
seek qualified air traffic controllers
anymore yeah Trump really very much
affected by just what goes on at
airports that's absolutely something
that is an issue for him uh last one and
uh then we'll move on very briefly to a
bonus clip Trump is still talking about
Hillary's emails in 2022. but almost as
bad crooked Hillary deleted 33 000
emails under Congressional subpoena
zavina
although I do believe they're in the
state department
because it's very hard to get rid of
them but they acid wash very expensive I
believe they're in the state department
Trump talks about emails as if they are
physical things it's very interesting
the process that's why Nobody Does it
she had four ideas in a box and then
pounded her phones with hammers making
them totally
unrecognizable to the naked eye so she
took those phones and she pounded the
hell out of them yeah so there's the
Hillary story and then here's just a
bonus check this out here is a woman a
Fiore I forget This Woman's first name
she just makes up unemployment numbers
that are completely untrue but the crowd
doesn't know any better
under President Trump we had a little
over three percent unemployment oh okay
do you know last time that happened
1969.
under Biden and Obama were at 10 percent
right and even more now that's
completely untrue we are at 3.5 percent
unemployment right now she says we are
at over 10 percent unemployment the
crowd doesn't seem to think much of it
these are just obvious lies but that
crowd welcomes all of it these rallies
continue to demonstrate the level of
delusion
and disconnection from reality that
these folks have and when we talk about
well how do we get them back how do we
get them back to sense it to to Common
Sense and normality
I don't know the answer because they
will accept whatever they are told later
in the show we'll see some interviews
with the rally goers all of these clips
if you're listening today you want to
see them in their full Glory destructive
Glory uh we'll have them on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show very quick break and
right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well it's
a very special day because we have today
returning to the program Mike Lindell
the CEO and inventor of my pillow known
affectionately to many in our audience
as Mike pillow or even just pillow the
word pillow it's like Madonna at this
point Mike it's really incredible The
Branding around that did you think it
this you would be so ubiquitous in the
United States sort of cultural milieu at
this point
no you know back when I invented my pill
I worked shows for years just doing home
shows and fairs and and it was uh it was
a hard seven year grind but then when we
did the first infomercial it kind of
went it was living in my sister's
basement and all of a sudden it you know
it just exploded and uh
um you know it's just uh I guess when we
did that first infomercial going to the
number one infomercial in the world in
30 days right it was uh it was kind of a
you know it was a dream come true the
American dream right so to speak yeah
listen I want to get right into the the
the context and the meat of this because
you and I spoke about a year ago and at
one point it wasn't clear if you
remembered that conversation but I know
you've reviewed it I want to run by you
the following you said over the last
couple years in August that Trump would
be back in office by the end of the
month that was August 2021 you said in
November of 2021 that it would be in the
Supreme Court by Thanksgiving that it
was quote locked in stone you said at
the end of 2021 that it was still
happening by the end of that year you
have made all of these specific time
predictions and as we know none of them
have happened why not
well there's a big reason for that the
evidence I got on January 9th was by a
person which I can come out with his
name now Dennis Montgomery he was a
whistleblower with the CIA he worked
with the CIA and the government for
years developing a thing called Hammer
scorecard okay and this is all the
information he gave me on January 9th
when we were going to release it at the
Cyber Symposium we were told because uh
there's a government gag order on it the
that we cannot release it but Dennis put
in to get it released about the same
time we did our show last year he put
that in and they said they wouldn't
release it we went ahead with the Cyber
Symposium we could show that we had the
data that it was from the 2020 election
but we couldn't show the back end data
there was on the third day they would
not let us show it my lawyer said no
they advised us to you know don't put it
out let's work on this gig or now years
went by and then I had the Moment of
Truth Summit about a month ago on stage
where Dennis has had this to get
released in Nevada I actually put myself
I bought the software now and so I own
it so I have the the X the software that
Dennis developed and everything and and
the data from the 2020 election now I
put in Nevada to get it released
um about a month ago just this last
Thursday the government came in and said
you can this is not going to be part of
the gag order so that is big news it's
breaking news I didn't know that when we
were going to get on your show so now we
can release it to the king I can bring
it to my lawsuits and we're subpoenaed
we subpoenaed on Friday Brennan Clapper
um Negra Ponte
um Baker We subpoenaed all these guys
you're probably not going to see that in
the news no well I can't imagine that
they'll respond to the subpoenas but
Mike you've mentioned so much let me
just make one comment here Dennis
Montgomery uh a con man I mean just an
out and out con man habitual liar
engaged in five major frauds uh
terrorist software hoax Nevada
gubernatorial bribery Scandal
wiretapping allegations that he has not
been able to prove we're talking about
an out and out con man here
um well you know what you can say that
but you can go to Dennis montgomery.com
now and all that has been completely
fabricated so if you go to Dennis
montgomery.com we put that up just for
comments like yours there because they
have attacked him but hold on a second
Mike I want to make sure I know what
you're saying here you're saying that
the reporting about Dennis Montgomery in
the New York Times uh the register from
the UK Bloomberg the Las Vegas Review
Journal New West Nevada today NPR wired
Courthouse News Service uh a USA Today
Las Vegas I I for it's all fake it's all
a lie yeah you know what David wow and
here's what I'm telling you is I'm
telling you that's why we put up the
David or the I mean the Dennis
montgomery.com page those what they've
done is just the same kind of attacks
I've gotten since I wanted to get rid of
the machines the voting machines in our
country which we'll get I was just ace I
was the Evangelist getting people I used
to be an addict getting people out of
addiction I have my company and I have
been relentlessly attacked just like
Dennis Montgomery was Dennis was never
arrested Dennis has been a gag order on
his on his data I mean you could say all
you want about Dennis Montgomery but
numbers speak for themselves well but
I'm not saying anything in my defense
Mike I'm just saying what you're alleged
I understand if you got the data which I
have and the government just said now we
can show it to the world you asked me
what was holding this back okay and by
the way the Supreme Court case there is
a case right now in the Supreme Court
okay it is almost 80 percent of what we
were going to have in the original
what's the name of that case I don't
have it I mean you can I can get a free
of David I did why don't you Caitlyn go
go ask her what the name of that what
the name of the game so okay I mean
there's just so much here Mike so the
10-year media record that goes from 2012
to 2022 on Dennis Montgomery you're
saying that was a decade-long effort to
smear him and it's all fake to to
suppress who they didn't want his data
coming out to the world and if you if
you go back there was even back in 2017
on Fox there was Sean Hannity Sarah
Carter another one they brought up
Dennis Montgomery it all got pushed out
of the table they did not not just the
2020 election this is the software is uh
it goes very deeper than that and that's
why the government just said that we can
release the 2020 election because that's
my evidence David right I do have
lawsuits against Me by companies uh
Dominion which everybody seems to
protect these companies that nobody knew
of before esns hard diable that you paid
for as a taxpayer and my whole thing is
here is you know what we can't have
computers running our elections you just
had it in Georgia where a Democrat this
nice lady her husband got zero votes in
her own Precinct and she they looked
into it she three Democrats she went
from third to four okay but Mike where I
want to try because you have so many
different areas in which you you claim
expertise and involvement I wanna we're
jumping around a lot let's kind of go
sequentially a little bit if we can so
you're going to get us the name of the
Supreme Court case you say that Dennis
Montgomery has been smeared over a
10-year period by 30 different media
Outlets okay the FBI we now know they
took the pillow phone at the Hardys
drive through
um just to set the context do you
frequently go to Hardee's is that a
common place you go okay that's pretty
funny David no it's not a joke but you
know I was coming back from a hunting
trip and I was late to get back I was
filming commercials with my
entrepreneurs for mystore.com they were
all waiting here and I said we've got to
go through a drive-through
and by the way when they surrounded me
they weren't dressed like FBI they were
no I know I know that's what happened at
night I would have bashed through them
and went to find a law enforcement
office you would have you would have
fled you're saying I would have
absolutely because they would they
didn't identify themselves I would have
thought they were bad guys I would if it
had been a night I I stepped out of my
car and said um who are you and what do
you want very loud so other people could
hear yeah and one guy says FBI and I
said show me your badge I don't believe
you another one to my right he says show
me yours I figure if they each had
badges I'll give them that okay and we
pulled and started talking there so
I I'm again I'm curious because you
there's a question of how they knew you
would be there do you often go to
Hardee's it's just a it's not a joke no
and I'm never I'm never in that town I
never eat in that town it was an hour
and a half from where I live okay and I
was like I say I was down in another
state hunting they obviously tracked me
which was illegal to track me they
didn't have a warrant and so that we did
sue the government and the FBI we've
sued him I know I know you have and we
first report for the fifth and sixth
amendment rights
I'm shocked you didn't add in and more
amendments to the lawsuit but we'll get
to that Mike I'm not I'm not a lawyer
the lawyers are lawyers I I my whole
thing was when they said we want your
phone yeah I said no you're not getting
my phone I said I want you know arrest
me I've done nothing wrong he said no
we're not going to arrest you I said
well I want to call my lawyer they said
no you don't get to call your lawyer and
I said well let me get this straight if
you arrest me I can call a lawyer but if
I if you don't arrest me I can't call a
lawyer but you can take my personal
property and this day everything's on a
person's phone and uh so they did let me
call the lawyer eventually here's what I
want to ask you about all of this Mike
I've previously interviewed two
individuals one named Carter page one
named Roger Stone
during the interviews they said they did
not believe they were going to be
charged ever and of course they
ultimately were is your expectation at
this point in time that you are going to
be criminally charged no that's not what
they're looking into they're looking
into somebody else somebody else I even
asked him about January 6. I said it's a
symbolving January 6 and they said no
and I said well why don't you bring me
there because I've offered to go there
even though I wasn't there on January
6th to show them all this evidence that
I can now show okay and um no absolutely
not that's not what this is about they
want stuff in there about a about a case
in Colorado okay that this this County
Clerk and Gina Peters yes and did her
job I didn't know her back then so this
is nothing to do this is like the Cyber
Symposium going forward and uh they're
just looking into the phone records by
the way which uh they could have got I
said here you go I have nothing to hide
I'm as transparent as they come David on
the issue of Tina Peters there have been
allegations I've read that at one point
you were essentially helping her hide
out to evade Justice is that true
the uh the in in after the Cyber
Symposium she I didn't I didn't fire
there but she made it to her lawyers
took her to Texas
um and when you say I'm hiding her out
no I didn't I didn't hide her out you
weren't involved in getting her to Texas
she wasn't at a property you owned you
weren't paying for a hotel room or
anything communication there whatsoever
I've got the name of that lawsuit if you
want please
um um no that's not that's not the
Nevada One the Nevada lawsuit is
Montgomery versus e trepid and case
number
306. we're looking for the Supreme Court
case you mentioned I want the Supreme
Court
okay
that that is like the Supreme Court for
the for the um election laws okay we'll
get that Supreme Court case I want to go
back to just one more detail of the FBI
thing then we'll move on to the machines
and everything else you just mentioned a
few minutes ago you said to the FBI
agents I'd rather go to jail than give
up my phone
because I knew I hadn't I've never done
I haven't done anything wrong no I get
that money but David here's my whole
reason okay the way we're at in our
country right now ever to get rid of
these machines I don't care if you're a
Democrat or Republican yeah the biggest
problem we have is law fair where Fox
News Newsmax Salem media none of these
guys talk the only one that ever talks
about it is people like you or Jimmy
Kimmel and I'm gladly come on your show
where I can actually say speak out these
guys they and you they've never said one
thing even 2 000 meals Newsmax and fox
will not let them on because of law fair
okay I thought gee maybe this would be
big enough news well they would put it
on Fox and they did okay the way they
did my question though was just going to
be you know that when you get arrested
they take all your stuff so like you
would have had to give up the phone
anyway right you know that but but I
would but Fox and Newsmax would have
Maybe started reporting about the
biggest gorilla that we have to get rid
of these Electronics I see if you had
guys arrested it would have gotten
publicity it's not overturning elections
it's getting rid of these machines and
having paper ballots hand counted like
so many other countries do the
Netherlands France Germany instead these
other countries that are gone forever
like Venezuela Australia they don't get
to ever have elections again their
selections and this has been proven out
there it's been proven over and over
again with these machine companies but
nobody will talk about it because of
what smartmatic did February 4th of 2021
when they sued Fox News okay on the
topic of the election I just want
straight from the horse's mouth Europe
the 2020 election or you want all these
other elections I've been investigating
2020 connected to 24. here's the
question
will Donald Trump be reinstated before
January 2025 which is when the next
winner is scheduled to be inaugurated
what would you like me to say David
whatever you believe I will tell you
whatever you believe I will here's my
answer yeah if we if we don't fix 2020
means getting rid of the electronic
voting machines melt them down and turn
them into prison bars we're not going to
have a country look what the damage has
been done in our country in two years by
what's been going on it's disgusting I
was just in Northern California all
these people there coming up to me
wanting pictures wanting to know him you
know do we have a chance to get ready we
don't like 7.80 gas is there a chance I
said you know what it all started with a
stolen election here's the Supreme Court
case it's called Moore versus Harper
it's case number
21-1271 and that is really critical to
our country because these are all the
things that the Secretary of States did
changed our laws when the legislatures
make the laws okay but to be clear Mike
that's a case I'm familiar with you said
you had a case at the Court this case
has nothing to do with you
no this case is is almost identical to
what we were going to bring to the
Supreme Court okay but this case has
nothing to do with this actually got to
the Supreme Court okay right now we
don't have to put a new one in we are
going to put one down with this evidence
and stuff to get rid of the machines but
what we want here is done in Arizona and
we've done in Alabama two preliminary
Junctions to get rid of these electronic
voting machines what we want on the
program what we want on the program is
just Clarity because I don't want
anybody to misunderstand when you said
you have that case that this case you
just cited has nothing to do with you
this case here is everything I would
have wanted to do but they they got they
we're in two tracks coming to the
Supreme Court okay they got there first
got it understood right to close one
other loop and we are making progress
here even if it doesn't realize that
just what I'm going to tell you
something just when you say you or
whatever this is all me that everything
every Focus out there all across our
country
um is to get rid of these electronic
voting machines which we will get to
momentarily so that I can move on to
that I didn't get an answer from you
about Will trump be reinstated before
January 25 what's your belief
my belief is I would hope that but but
you know I I can't say there's no with
the evidence now yeah that would come
out that I can release with Dennis
Montgomery I don't know you know I don't
know in the way the way we're in now
nothing it's it's like um the we've
never been in an anomaly like this in
history where where there's it's a
lawless Society you have you know you
have things going on where you're going
how does Pennsylvania turn in their
electors which is illegal with more
votes than voters that didn't happen of
course yeah but that's that did happen
it did not happen did happen David no
you're then you'd misconstrued or lying
they they turned in their electors with
more votes than voters in Pennsylvania
and every and it went through and
everyone's called them out on it but
they've it's still sitting there it
hasn't been pulled down and looked at to
say how did this happen okay you know
and and that's a fact you can sit here
you can have Alan Duke fact check you if
you'd like there is no state that has
more yeah anything like this uh you know
in like in in Georgia when that Democrat
got zero votes they had to look at it
because they didn't they could have gave
her two or her and her husband at least
got a vote another Democrat in Georgia
this is this summer another Democrat
this other lady she got 3 700 votes and
she wasn't on the ballot we are going to
pause our conversation there with Mike
Lindell the full conversation will be on
the YouTube channel youtube.com the
David packman show we'll take a quick
break and be back
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right having a sort of recovered
from that wild interview let's look at a
couple of other things I did want to
just briefly go over uh some of the
assertions made by attendees at both of
the Trump rallies over the weekend
Saturday in Nevada and Sunday in Arizona
uh in Arizona there was a woman who said
something that it just sounds wrong to
say about a trump speech listen to this
okay and what brought you out to the
Trump rally today president Trump what
are you looking for people what are you
looking forward to see from here today
oh my gosh the unity and the healing and
just to move on and we just have to heal
as a nation and come together again
and the truth
unity and healing and certainly truth
are not common occurrences common
features of a trump rally in fact I just
saw a list of at a recent rally there
were about 40 different people or
organizations that Donald Trump attacked
but it's interesting how you can really
see in it anything you want even if it's
not there one of the wackiest pre-rally
moments at the Arizona rally was a woman
doing oh man I don't even know how to
explain this doing some kind of speed
drawing of Jesus and the hosts saying
you know it is Sunday after all it's a
very spiritual moment so is she she's
just living element she's a beautiful
woman painting for a large crowd of
American Patriots and obviously
Christina it's a spiritual moment for
her as well on this on this Sunday on
this Sunday uh it's this very spiritual
moment that she's having with us right
now and it's just beautiful
yeah so they uh the woman does seem to
be having some kind of an issue then
they that they interviewed a guy with a
Second Amendment God's guns and guts
shirt and this guy he tells a sort of
sad story of for some reason having lost
many friends recently also lost a lot of
friends because I'm a trump fan I don't
understand it but you know what we're
all for we're all in for him yeah yeah
you know what we're going to pray for
those people who cannot open their eyes
right and find out how great Trump is
for this country and Kerry Lake and of
course you got the whole roster of some
great conservative Republicans to
represent the state yes sir yeah okay
got your second amendment as well I love
that God's gone guts I have everything
yeah
cool haircut um yeah
um I don't know if the guy is serious I
mean it's a interesting haircut
nonetheless but
um just really it's perplexing how could
this guy possibly have lost any friends
and you know what really strikes me
about these interviews is you know
imagine you go up to a guy like this and
you say hey you know what the tariffs on
China were actually not good
uh for the United States and we imagine
they go oh you know what that yeah
that's true that makes sense
these are folks that are so deep down
the rabbit hole that it just simply It
seems impossible it seems impossible
another guy now going to the Nevada
rally the previous day
a guy at the Nevada rally had an
incredible conspiracy theory about
what's happening in Ukraine listen to
this and the thing that really makes me
mad about Ukraine we put the bioweapon
labs under Obama and Obama said oh yeah
we'll give it give up the nukes and we
got your back we help causes with
Ukraine under Obama
so I understand why Russia is in there
doing what they're doing with the whole
denotification of the Don boss region
because so many Ukrainian nationalists
uh seem to be full-blown Nazis these
days a lot of the media I've seen come
out of the Russians taking PW these guys
got swastikas all over them tattooed and
I'm like oh our media doesn't like to
play that though it's really interesting
how that works yeah you know we've
talked about this there is a there's a
small Nazi presence in Ukraine but this
is just a completely whacked conspiracy
theory Obama's really responsible
because he built bio labs in Ukraine and
made Russia give up nukes and so that's
what I mean it's just unhinged and it's
so it's wound up so tight that I don't
know how you undo it here's another
woman at the Trump rally who says she
loves Putin and it's sort of like not
exactly the message that I think they're
trying to associate with their movement
but it is what it is and
but Russia and a Ukraine conclave
conflict and I love Putin I love Putin
Putin is making the right you know but
the the American people is built over
there he wants to clean them out you
know
clean them out all the the
biochemical Place everything and the
nuclear thing yeah we'll have to talk
more about this because
good president you know number two of
the president one number two yeah I mean
listen this is these are the these
people gravitate towards
authoritarian autocrats and so they
really do see
Trump and Putin or poutine
as similar
and it's not exactly the message that
right side broadcasting and all these
different networks want to want to put
out there and portray uh but it is
accurate it is it is what it is
um here's just one last one this one's
from the also the Nevada rally here's a
woman who just talks again about all the
things she likes about Trump and none of
them are true I'd love him and I think
he's he's the kindest gentlest man he
listens and he's not a bully like they
tried it you know and he's mean but he's
absolutely I mean just look at his
children they don't smoke they don't
drink president Trump I mean he did
something right so there's a perspective
and I guess maybe the most false claim
in there is
um he's not a bully I mean it's hard to
think of a bigger bully so uh
are these folks Beyond reach is it
Beyond repair is are they too far gone
um let me know what you think and then
we will follow up it's the Perpetual
question as at least as far as it
affects elections we care about it
Marjorie Taylor green radical republican
congresswoman she spoke at uh one of the
Trump rallies at this point who even
knows which one it is she is not even
pretending anymore she is fully doing
the replacement Theory thing this is the
white replacement Theory or great
replacement Theory take a listen
Joe Biden's five million illegal aliens
are on the verge of replacing you
replacing your jobs and replacing your
kids in school and coming from all over
the world they're also replacing your
culture and that's not great for America
for a long time we knew that these folks
were pushing this idea
but they still had to sort of pretend
not to or they had to couch it in
different language or they had to figure
out a way to make the case that it's not
horribly xenophobic and in many cases
racist they've given up on that and the
idea here there's kind of two layers to
this white replacement Theory great
replacement Theory the idea is the left
Democrats Marxist Communists like fill
in the blanks right whoever whoever it
is that they claim is doing this stuff
the George Soros right fill in the
blanks
they are they are actively trying to
bring people into the United States
including through undocumented
immigration
in order to replace
the current demographic realities of the
United States another way to say it is
the left is deliberately by any possible
means that that they can think of
trying to change the racial and ethnic
makeup of the United States in order to
then what whatever you know when
elections change the culture or whatever
that's the idea of it and it's often
kind of the undertone to a lot of the
reporting on shows like Tucker Carlson
and others about immigration and the
debate around immigration
that's what it is
the there's many issues with it but one
of the issues that exists with that is
that if you start to believe what
Marjorie Taylor green is saying
you start to justify
violence
attacks domestic terrorism whatever
against Americans against the country
against leftists because you believe
that that is what they are doing you
start to believe there's a concerted
effort to root out white people
generally is the way that it goes and
when Marjorie Taylor green says this
stuff it is a form of stochastic
terrorism that could incite or encourage
exactly those types of attacks so this
is extraordinarily dangerous rhetoric
um you know you're never going to charge
her over it as we've talked about before
whether it's Tucker doing it or whoever
not going to charge them for it
certainly not under the current law and
I'm not necessarily even arguing the law
should be changed I mean we have free
speech and there's limits but they're
quite loose okay but we have to
understand this for what it is it is
painting an untrue picture of the goals
of those left-wingers that they talk
about and it's dangerous it's xenophobic
it's racist it's all of these things the
crowd it resonates with the crowd
but they don't even really understand
how they're being manipulated and sort
of directed by it and they're not going
to stop because they're doing really
well pushing exactly this sort of stuff
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P I think it's sort of in
reaction to the Kanye West anti-Semitism
controversy I got an interesting email
take a listen to this
hey David it's James again I was just
wondering uh do you think that most
anti-Semitism comes from people who
don't know any Jews
um because I I don't know a whole lot of
juices
um but the ones that I had met are
really lovely people uh I'd say they're
more more christ-like
than probably more Christians than I met
um
yeah so do you think it's because they
don't know any Jews or because they do
know Jews and don't like them
so the thing about I I've met lots of
people in my life who when they find out
I'm Jewish they go I've never met a
Jewish person before
it's almost always
they've never met a Jewish person that
they were aware of but like most people
unless you live in extremely rural
places you know certain parts of the
country
it's just not obvious like you know when
you meet a black person you can tell
that they're black
um
so when people say oh I've never met a
Jewish person it's actually you probably
just didn't realize it now from to this
to this question is the anti-Semitism
because these folks have never met a
Jewish person or they didn't didn't like
them I don't think it's related at all
to personal experience in many ways for
most of the folks that I've met it's
based on stories that they heard over
and over and over again as they were
growing up regardless of who they
personally knew that's my that's my
sense that's my instinct we have a great
bonus show for you today just me on the
bonus show today producer Pat a little
bit under the weather he'll be back very
soon we will talk about
it's happening again
40 of Republicans say they will blame
election fraud if they don't win
they're already saying if we don't win
we're going to blame election fraud also
big problems for Electric Vehicle
Manufacturer rivien
who has had almost had to recall almost
all of their electric trucks
not good and we will talk about upcoming
debates the Spanish Channel
possibilities that are being discussed
and many many more things get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at joinpakman.com it's quick it's easy
you can use the coupon code big voting22
the meaning should be obvious as we are
just weeks away from the midterm big
boating 22 at joinpackman.com